so hello everyone my name is nice top
music and I'm postdoctoral associate at
the Michigan State University working
with Ashley shade in in the Department
of Microbiology and like genetics so
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to present to you our plan microbiome
work in particularly how we go about to
study the common be microbial I hope I
will come easy at the end of my talk
about three things first the common bean
is an important crop an appealing model
system for studying plant microbe
interactions secondly that plant
rhizosphere is a very diverse and
complex system and third and finally
that plants consistently recruit a
number of microbes from the soil
suggesting an intimate relationship
between the plant and these microbes as
mentioned before I'm a postdoctoral
researcher in the group of Master Shake
and what our main research team is
microbial stability and what role plays
microbial diversity in this process so
if you look at this figures here on on
your screen
after ecosystem goes in perturbation or
stressed or a stress the community in
this ecosystem goes into a period of
fluctuation and this fluctuation can
then lead into two end results first
result can be and the desired result is
a stable state which is which means that
the functionality of the system is very
similar to the pre pre perturbation stay
however on the other hand the community
can go into an alternative state which
is unstable and usually has negative
consequences for the system so not just
for the system this has effect also on
the plant health so what we want to
understand is how micron
microbial communities respond to stress
and use this knowledge them to manage
these communities to be stable and
resilient in the future so our approach
to study the plant microbiome resilience
consists of three parts so first of all
we want to understand how this
communities looked like so who is their
president our plants selecting person
some taxa are the host genotype effects
on those community assemblies and
community compositions does seasonal
effects or even as I said before clan
both active communities so we're
approaching this - with the using the
unclick on sequencing but what we do
next is exposing the systems to stresses
and what do we do that is to understand
more how how the system works and how
the functionality of such microbial
systems look like under stress
conditions so when we are doing theories
using the antipas sequencing combining
with a metagenomics finally we are very
interested in the functionality of these
systems and trying to better understand
what microbial functions are are
involved in in this in this strands
conditions for the plants and which we
can be also having a effect and
implementation in implementation and
health so we are using method
transcriptomics and that along for this
part to investigate so as microbiologist
we are very fortunate to be surrounded
by experts in plant sciences we are part
of two large research efforts one is the
trend resilience institute that is
funded by the Michigan State University
and the other one is the Great Lakes
bioenergy Research Center which is
funded by the gue our research model
system includes a variety of plants that
are including the bioenergy crops such
as switchgrass and Miscanthus we were
also studying the apples but
as when my title to talk already
suggests we were focusing lately very
much into common being or the visuals
regardless so what do we care about and
why would we focus about a common theme
so there are two reasons firstly common
mean has importance for the society
ready and it has economical agricultural
environmental but also health benefits
and secondly it is an attractive system
for science due to its unique
diversification and cultivation history
it is a model to study the impact of
plant evolution and domestication of
plants microbe interactions so the
versification of this plant started
around around 160,000 years ago when the
common beam ancestor started migrating
from its origin in central Mexico to
Central and South America interestingly
two domestication bans happened
simultaneously approximately 8,000 years
ago one in Mesoamerica munition and one
in the Andean region which the infirm
were actually isolated this germ plasm
and speciation cheering the figures you
can see the nowadays germ plasm that
exist in the wild and you can already
see the distinct lineages between the
Mesoamerican and Andean and this mean
this separation is not just in their
genotype but also in their phenotype and
traits so definitely there is a major
problem in concerned regarding the
common bean namely that the yields and
production area are predicted to be
decreased you due to the impact of the
global change that being said it's a
biotic and because of my expenses
especially many stress related to
climate change are affecting the
production of the common bean as you can
see also here so however there are still
germ plasm the which has resilient rates
and can be bred into the modern
cultivars this can be achieved through
traditional breeding and you can see
that in this picture where some of the
beans let's end the drought conditions
and are experiencing stress and then
dying off however on the other hand we
have some germ plasm that is tolerant of
the truck and this is pregnant in turn
breath into modern cultivars this is a
tedious strategy and usually takes
decades to achieve the other alternative
can approach what we believe is also
very advantageous with many other groups
is to to do that with microbiome
engineering and what do we think about
it or what we consider as from
microbiome engineering there is a nice
paper by Valen sting in 2017 with a very
nice figure so what we are thinking
again would be this engineering this we
we can use different stimulations
iron in in life microbes microbial
communities or even substances that will
boost the environment functionality and
diversity and this will then become
again an healthy and natural looking as
it's in the picture of a we know as well
the our modern intense intense
agriculture systems tend to be degraded
that means that they're depleted in the
diversity and in their functional
redundancy so any strands that will hit
such systems my my term is like there is
a high likelihood that these functions
can be lost forever
and then even more degraded system so
engineering is the process where we can
actually push the system or even improve
the degree the credit system check to a
more natural healthy environment so
our research what we're focusing is and
is to understanding the natural
occurring microbiota for this purposes
it has also been of course benefits
under stress conditions so however there
are some problems with this and this is
because the rhizosphere in the soil
ecosystems are one of the most most
diverse ecosystem on the planet in this
figure you can see the diversity of
microbial diversity occurs different
ecosystems and highlighted the errors
are one
it's the rhizosphere and the other one
is soil and you can see clearly that
those ecosystems are truly very diverse
and this diversity then how do we find
the ones that are actually essential for
the plant so what we think is is by
defining the core and what we mean with
this is the final set of microbes that
are found most samples of a particular
plant and will help to identify them the
plant associated microbes there should
be prioritized for the future research
what is an additional aspect of the core
isn't it flex underlying functional
relationship with the host and so we can
use them really Trinity for that purpose
the common being though the common being
microbiome though it's very under
investigated so we don't know clearly
who is associated with this important
plant so to defend someone on this we
started the project where we are looking
at actually the common being microbiome
and defined the core so we use different
approaches one of them we combine
different approaches and one of them is
biogeography biogeography is the study
of species distribution across
geographical locations and was
traditionally used in the animal and for
plants however also bacteria or microbes
can show some biography called patterns
here in this map you can see some
distribution of
marine environment associated microbes
some that are more distributed across
different oceans and some there Amarula
localized next what we are also using
and combining here is the using of micro
ecological concepts in mutual modeling
plus call currents network analysis both
of the concepts I will introduce to you
in a minute
so whatever how does our experimental
look like design look like we've focused
on two we selected two very distinct
genotypes as I said one from the
Mesoamerican one for andi'm diversity
panel the Mesoamerican diversity panel
is comprised from the ship's genotypes
the black bean and the CBL are okay or
California early life red kidney which
is a red candy bean they are not just
you know typically very different but
also fennel typically and their traits
are very different
so if we find that there is some that
the genotype the planting of that has
any impact on the communities we should
clearly detect that with these two
genotypes only two genotypes so those
plants at five different location across
us and these locations are also
considered as one of the top producers
of the common beam this is location not
just different their geographical
distribution but also in their stolen
properties from pH to differ phosphorus
levels organic matter but also their
climate and management some obtaining
fertilizations not some new healthier
engagements and so our approach now was
to to harvest those beans
isolate the DNA from the rhizosphere and
amplified the 16s rRNA gene for
understanding the communities of
bacteria and archaea as well as ideas
region to target the fungal community
systems we use the
applicants to to sequence on the
aluminum Isaac and analyze those by
clustering the reads into operational
taxonomic unions or ot used at the 97%
similarly what an OT or operational
taxonomic unit is it could be equivalent
to a species in animal world or our
pilot world so this data said has been
used them for various analysis which I'm
gonna present to you right now
so the results of this study are as
following so what we found is that there
are study this study showed that there
is a strong effect of growth growing
location on the be near as escaped
minutes but there is no effect of the
host genotype we have used mera analysis
which includes samples from the US our
study plus the study done in Colombia
and we have on 48 taxa that represent
the cross-continental moreover these
cortex are not hog taxa and mainly are
low abundant results from the combined
concurrence analysis and neutral
modeling than also suggested this cortex
are are in an intimate relationship with
the host plant and rather than theme
these species in the soil environment so
let me just show you know some data
supporting these results so to
investigate the community composition
and the effect of the soil properties
the management or the climate we have
used ordination analysis and Fuhrman OVA
we were surprised actually to see that
the common bean genotype did not
correlate with the community composition
as it was found in recent studies but
the story is deferring the their growing
conditions so as seeing the figure here
represented in the principle coordinate
analysis how we read this figure or the
practice like every dot represents
community structure if the dots the
samples are closely together that means
that the community composition
of these sides are very similar more
this distance the points are the more
distended the communities are so by
color-coding you see the points with the
same color tend to be organized for
grouping together
suggesting that they are very similar by
location so that further make us first
believe that the decor might not be
present
however despite significant differences
in microbial composition between this
growing locations the community composed
of a very similar microbial taxa and
thus we were still like than speculated
we can still make me find a quarter
since you can see here in the Venn
diagram that almost more than 2,000
texts have been found as they start so
to determine the core by an investigator
to investigate the core we relied on the
occupancy abundance relations and an
example of it is presented here in this
graph below for each section or the
species are my microbe in this community
mean and relative abundance is
calculated and then plotted against its
detection frequency which we terminus
and occupancy so the higher the points
are in this graph the more travel than
the taxa are in this dataset so this
relationship is also a starting point
Ernest and the community assembly
mechanisms by using them the neutral
modelling which is represented in the
line so we have used this lone neutral
model which was also implemented by
others especially burns it all which
assumes that for AXA with high abundance
we should expect also higher occupancy
and then also vice versa so taxon there
are always some some tax of the dump all
this rule and those DBA from this we can
call them as deviated deviation from
this neutral model and those tax
are in particular interest for us
because these are assembled through
deterministic processes or selection and
we that have ecological importance so
when we apply this relationship between
what we first seed is that they for
approximately 22,000 peoples or species
in the system detected across 30 samples
many taxa are shared in wide and only
few of them are three teeny genotype
specific as highlighted in the colors
are in from lack this this just confirms
the previous data with their donation
analysis
so when more over than when we applied
the neutral model the community overall
fits pretty nicely to today to it
however there is still an almost 40% of
accents deviated from this model and
most of them interestingly architected
to be involved with tradition or the
prediction where selection for tourists
microbes can be assigned to so due to
the large number of taxidermy fine in
this system we decide to use a very very
strict threshold and this is - for
defining the core and this is all the
taxa or species there are having options
one meaning that they are found in every
single stack that we have and you can
imagine we have collected the samples
across very different geographical
locations with very different properties
and from two very different plants
everything what we found here is very
very strictly so we identified almost
250 bacterial and archaeal taxa that
following these very strict thresholds
and even more 171 of this taxa are
predicted above the neutral model so
next we what we wanted to do is to
investigate the importance of this core
taxa so recent research actually such as
a microbial attack sir I
drivers of plant health and how to
determine if their attacks
well then it's usually done by
correlation network analysis or
Corcoran's tantric Nasus so for these
for those last familiar with the network
terminology a hobbies a species in the
community highly correlated with many
different members and it has an
importance and implication for for
community assembly for community
functionality but also overall and for
our ecosystem so in many cases
biological networks them to be modular
and a module it's a prove of taxa
species those that are highly correlated
with each other and here in this figure
depicted in red highlighted in red or
blue
there are also species terminus
connectors and those are the species
that are connecting two hubs
or two modules excuse me and everything
else that is there are term as
peripheral taxa so there are two
parameters that can be used to
distinguish these four categories of
nodes this is the within the CI and
between the P I module connectivity as
seen here in the scatter plot the result
is this plot the scatter plot which is
split into four section and each
represents in this porc degrees so the
outer layers being the most important
item being the module talks that were
capsule enactors and in internal ones
that is the peripherals which are tend
to be low connected to within the module
but also be the modules so when we use
this model this method in our array that
we founded our cortex are non hub text
except we found wanted some out of 270
that we want to the Furman family he
forgot
which was determined as a model hub and
then one connected species belonging to
an interim vector Pham
out of 270 tax actually 75 only showed
significantly sadistically significant
correlation with other taxa and most of
them have not been included in those so
suggesting the predominantly is a cortex
and which tend to be very ubiquitously
and found with with with a common bean
plant our peripheral or not very well
connected community what are the
peripheral tax is a logical perspective
these are the specialists and so can we
think of that these are specialists for
the plant still the question that we are
trying to trust so to validate our
results actually what we looked for
studies that use as well next generation
sequencing approaches using the common
bean of course right and brightest here
we found actually a perfect study that
was ideal to come early and included the
16s rRNA religion same two hours it has
additional 7 min genotypes which were
sampled at flowering time as well as
what we did and but the difference is
that they were grown in the controlled
environment in Colombia so results from
that actually surprised us and since we
found a large overlap a large overlap in
the membership between the study
disbanding
so differed we found 48 taxa that are
shared between the cores of each dataset
having the colombian
core and in the US or represented by the
tax up with the occupancy 1 and who are
earnest Texan predominantly this tax I
belong to the to the proteomic team here
but
they are still like nuances in their
relative abundances between the dataset
some like my Krakow Calais down below
tend to be more abundant in the u.s.
than in the Colombian solos however is
finger muna Dallas members belonging to
Desmond comunidades tend to be more
abundant in the Colombian samples
persons compared to the US so what what
is the reasoning behind it is not clear
but we could speculate that these tags
are are in intimate relationship with
the host and then the host depending on
Queens needs the modulates their
abundances and activities so with that
we kind of represent and presented a
manageable number of taxa which our
future research can actually target them
so but we are not the only one in search
of the core of the plant core many users
studies have done similar research and
other crops and plant species and in all
with the same action objective to find a
Saturday tag so that could have
application potentials so what we have
done next is that we use a publicly
available data set and also there is
actually a universal or rhizosphere
microbial so to do that it's a said we
used we search for publicly available
data and found 18 different study
studies including 18 different plant
species that were grown and time
different countries represented in total
by 240 samples crossed off studies what
we did we process all the data using
different workflows or new search mother
time and classify the weeds by syllable
database the results are actually pretty
surprising to us so the trash holds that
we have used are slightly different
previously here our threshold was that
there the occupancy of attacks on must
be greater than 0.5 within the study and
so half of you say that there should
have this tax on within this time plus
the other threshold should be that this
if they have this occupancy
they should also shows you with all the
plants in the meta data that we
collected so looking at this data set we
see now highlighted in the in the in the
in the black that we found anything taxa
that are shared regardless of the plan
that we included and then tends been
aging different plants being lighter
wild plants or domesticated plants even
more when we looked at the at the when
we when we separated the plants into
let's say domesticated of the crops and
the wire plants this core membership
drastically increased and inflated so
when we look at the novel domesticated
domesticated plants almost six more than
600 tax are have been found by using
this attraction and when conferring the
wild plants have still have lower but
still high amounts of membership that is
can be determined support with 200 taxa
so this is really surprising to us and
it's we are currently investigating that
more into that but who are those
cosmopolitan and a dominant or the
dominant taxa so they are predominantly
belonging to the of a particular group
still attending that we see differences
from planted plant some plants have more
opportunity in the matters but what is
the consequences of these differences
still unclear mentioning already at the
beginning were very interesting
functional
Quora microbes and also in particularly
not in this data set and how do you
understand that from the data that we
have collected right now from have the
consequences that's difficult or almost
impossible so what's needed is to do for
studies and what an initiated it's a
study that involves again common pin and
was conducted from the Summer 2018 where
we were looking at how community
microbial community actually develops on
the on the on the plant throughout the
plant growth or development where we
also included the previously been
genotypes the C ELR K and clips and grew
them and the two exactly same equations
in the Michigan which is the Saginaw
Valley and calm we in this time this
time we not did not just focus on the
biosphere so the root architecture part
but also looked at the biosphere or the
above-ground communities as well as the
atmosphere communities or the
communities that reside within the plant
so we are here questioning whether and
how the communities develop on the plant
through the planned development as the
does that has consequences or even for
the functionality these community
compositions and of this community
structures but also what are potential
of these microbes in the systems so for
now we have only preliminary data from
the amplicon sequencing and what is nice
that these data support previously store
results that the plan gene and I had no
effect and that the site has a strong
effect on the community composition
moreover what we see that a compartment
will be sampled and analyzed as well as
time they also have very strong
community structure in fact so how this
community straw
two differences transition into
functionality it's still unclear and
this is hopefully with obtaining the
metagenomics data and data transcript
and data we will be able to address that
so to summarize now my talk it's what we
found is under flow conditions plan
genotype does not influence the common
in registered community we also find
that in plan or tax I have potentially
planned beneficial traits for which they
are then recruited by the plants that's
in support violence hi there high
occupancy predictability or deviation
from the neutral model more even more
what we can also are these if the plant
cortex are not important players and so
on microbial communities because they
are meaty correlated with other tax and
the network analysis that the plant
development that will compare those
strong drivers of the community
composition in the resolution
environment but we still don't know how
that affects the functionality we also
found with the meta-analysis that there
are different plant species that to
recruit similar microbial tax whether
there is actually existing a plant Cosmo
point cosmopolitan the taxon is yet to
be determined
so from this descriptive let's say
studies we actually know initiated a
number of very excited projects looking
at more functionality of this microbiome
or microbiota and we are currently
working on assessing the aspects of seed
microbiome and it's impacting the
expressed tolerance in plants we're
trying to understand how actually plants
communicating needs in their truths
stole beneficial microbiota particularly
looking at the role by the organs we are
also trying to understand how actually
much microbes
contribute to observe tolerance implants
and moreover what we want to actually
achieve as well as sustainable growth of
plants right this is by using native
microbiome members and using those were
systemic so with that I'd like to thank
you for your attention thank thanks to a
substrate for gaming opportunity to work
on this exciting project all the members
of the Freid lab as well as the funding
agencies for supporting our work and for
of course the resources of Michigan
State University at the end I want to
invite you to visit our github
repository if you're interested in any
knowledge ease data data wrangling and
bioinformatics points and workflows that
we used in the lab with a thank you very
much if you have any question for
questions I will be available on online
email thank you